this is raven abbas also known by his
instagram handle hush puppy he's a
nigerian real estate tycoon a
multi-millionaire and a popular
influencer with over 2.7 million
instagram followers in every sense of
the word hush puppy was a baller his
instagram is filled with picks with him
in cars like a 300 000 rose voice and a
200 000 ferrari when he flies on a
private jet by the way or a pj for those
unacquainted he warms himself up with
louis vuitton blankets in his home a
penthouse suite in a crazy expensive
building in dubai
hush puppy wasn't always rich but he had
built himself up to becoming one of the
biggest businessmen and influencers in
nigeria it was the classic rags the
richest story everyone who knew him
wanted to be like him there was
literally no limit to his money and he
made sure that everyone online knew
that's there was only one problem
everything anyone knew about hush puppy
was live a lie that would cost him all
his money cars and designer clothes
it lie that left him right back to where
he started as a poor kid from nigeria
but to understand how hush puppy ended
up losing at all we have to travel back
in time to when he was just a boy
growing up on the streets of lagos
nigeria
this is the story of raymond abbas also
known as hush puppy and how one
instagram post helped the fbi catch one
of the biggest online scammers in
history
a true nigerian prince
[Music]
[Music]
public is a social investing app where
you can easily invest in stocks etfs and
crypto with any amount of money and
millions of people are already taking
advantage of it public is a serious game
changer because you can follow other
investors right in the app to learn what
they invest in this gives you an unheard
of advantage never before seen in
investing now you don't have to just
listen to what people say and take their
word for it but you get to see where
people actually put their money because
as they say actions speak much louder
than words i'm also on public you can
follow me at jtran and what's great is
that the public app is free and there
are no commissions on standard stock
trades public always puts its investors
first they'll never sell your trades to
market makers and instead your trades
are rather directly to the exchanges and
with public you can buy small slices of
a stock etf or crypto instead of the
full share there are thousands of stocks
and etfs to choose from and over 20
different cryptos like bitcoin cardano
and ethereum and if you go to public.com
jake train and create an account you'll
get a free stock worth anywhere from
three to a thousand dollars that's
public.com to get a free stock with the
link below thanks to public for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
if you came across hush puppy anytime in
the last decade you would have never
imagined he grew up poor because he was
flashy to the max
raymond was so poor that his father
worked as a taxi driver in lagos nigeria
and his mom saw bread on the side of the
road just to make ends meets when
raymond was old enough he started
washing cars to try to make a couple
cents on the side to the world raymond
abbas wasn't millionaire material and he
knew it
but around the same time raymond reached
his 20s nigeria was in the middle of his
first major international exports
internet gamers it started off from
small internet cafes around lagos these
kids would take a chance and make up
some nigerian prince story to try to
scan their way to an extra couple bucks
even if they were cuts it wasn't like
rich americans were going to launch an
international investigation over a
thousand dollars from the first
international scam artist called yahoos
a thousand dollars was a massive score
all from the comfort of their computer
internationally it was a small time
hustle at best a hustle no one really
paid any attention to no one except for
a few yahoos who recognized their
potential to make even more money than
any kid from nigeria could ever dream of
and one of them was none other than
raymond abbas
[Music]
[Music]
officially raymond abbas made his
millions through hard work and clever
investments whenever anyone asked him
how he got started the answer would
always be real estates good enough to be
believable boring enough for people not
to ask any follow-up questions no one
cared to ask how he got into real
estates how he made his first money to
invest or why he didn't seem to do any
actual work at all in a time when guys
like donald trump built a billion dollar
empire on real estates people just took
his answer at face value and left it at
thats but the truth of raymond abbas's
millions was actually a lot more
colorful than the world believed after
spending years perfecting his online
scam trade raymond decided nigeria was a
little too small for his dreams and made
the move to kuala lumpur malaysia
according to everyone who knew raymond
he was heading to malaysia to study but
the truth he was looking for bigger and
better opportunities outside of his home
country around that same time the
instagram persona hush puppy was born at
first it was just an unknown instagram
handle but soon hush puppy would have
thousands of followers
like his backstory early hush puppy
posed for pictures of raymond in a small
apartment or out in the streets of
malaysia nothing flashy but the more
money he made from his side hustle the
more he started wanting to flex his
wealth online raymond had always loved
designer brands and clothes now with all
this money from his online businesses he
finally had the chance to buy the stuff
he could only dream of as a kid but just
buying it wasn't enough either not when
he had experienced years of people
telling him he would amount to nothing
oh no it was time to show off what his
hard work had earned him it was time to
stick it to the haters at hushpuck he
started innocently enough just to wait
for raymond abbas to get all the
validation he always wanted little did
he know that that same instagram account
would land him in prison just a few
years later
[Music]
the billionaire gucci master that's
where raymond started calling himself
every day he would post pics of him
wearing thousands of dollars worth of
designer clothes standing in front of
insanely expensive cars and staying at
only the best hotels around the world
and unlike other influencers he wasn't
just using the clothing cars as props he
actually owned them his suite at the
palazzo versace in dubai it cost him
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
his 150 thousand dollar diamond
encrusted watch it wasn't on loan he
actually owned it hush puppy had made it
in every sense of the word he wasn't
just an instagram influencer anymore he
was slowly clawing his way into the
ranks of the ultra wealthy and his
favorite story telling the world how he
was once denied a french visa when he
tried to leave nigeria now he was
staying in the ritz hotel in paris on an
all-expenses paid fashion week trip from
louis vuitton and people ate it up
everywhere people were looking to hush
puppy as the example of what happens
when you hustle for your dreams the
story of raymond abbas working himself
from rags to riches was something
everyone wanted to believe and when
people want to believe something so
badly no amount of evidence would make
them change their minds hush puppy
probably thought they would believe his
story forever
[Music]
[Applause]
to others hush puppy was just another
flexor on instagram with more money than
he knew what to do with but hush puppy
loved the attention he loved the fact
that people treated him like royalty he
loved his peasant followers yes he
actually called them peasants
who hung onto every word of his cliche
captions
on the surface he was just another
filthy rich entrepreneur and the people
who didn't hate him wanted to be him but
out of all his haters and fans there was
one group hush puppy didn't really want
watching him the fbi you see for years
the fbi had been keeping track of a
group of online scammers who has stolen
millions of dollars from businesses and
people around the world their
investigations had led them to a lot of
hush puppies friends in fact by 2019 two
of hush puppies best friends and
colleagues have been arrested for fraud
and money laundering this suddenly got
people asking questions about how hush
puppy made his money in nigeria people
who knew raymond abbas as a kid started
posting online wondering how he went
from washing cars to owning some of the
most expensive ones in the world
something didn't add up something was
seriously wrong there was no record of
any real estate deals where raymond
abbas had been involved was he involved
in his friend's scheme somehow or had he
made all his money from faking it long
enough to become an influencer slowly
the pieces of the puzzle of hush puppy's
life started falling into place and on
october 11 2019 a hush puppy birthday
post gave the fbi everything they needed
to come after him
[Music]
hush puppy's 37th birthday as always he
documents everything he does on
instagram from the party at burberry
dubai's vip lounge to sushi at nobu and
monaco facials a christian dior spot in
paris and champagne as favorite brand
gucci it was just hush being hush but
little did he know that the fbi was
tracking his every move and this
birthday appreciation post had just
given them everything they needed you
see hush puppy has real phone number
connected to his instagram and his real
email so using these posts fbi confirmed
his birthday his identity and his
location throughout the day how did this
implicate him in a massive scam well
with all that tracking information the
fbi managed to link all his movements
throughout the day with the movements of
no conspirators and one of the biggest
online scam syndicates in history all
his friends from his birthday party they
were under investigation too and there
was no way hush puppy wasn't also a part
of their scheme
[Music]
sunday june 7 2020 the final puzzle
pieces fall into place and an arrest
warrant is issued for hush puppy and his
friends monday morning around 1am dubai
police forced their way into hush puppy
suites at the palazzo versace at the
same time similar raids happen across
the city and 11 other suspects all
friends with hush puppy are arrested 47
cell phones 21 laptops seven million
dollars worth of cars and 40 million
dollars in cash was confiscated hush
puppy is extradited to america where he
pleads guilty to being a part of a
syndicate that scammed american and
european businesses out of almost half a
billion dollars but how in this day and
age where nigerian internet scams are so
well known did a group of guys manage to
gain people out 450 million dollars how
did anyone with that kind of money
believe their stories and how did the
fbi finally figure out who it was well
it turns out hush puppy's scheme was a
lot simpler than you think
[Music]
and his team ran what the fbi calls a
bec scam or a business email compromise
scheme here's how it works hush and his
team will send out phishing emails to a
company staff a staff member falls for
it and shares some vital company info
then the team takes that information and
uses it to access the company's official
email accounts once they do this they
start monitoring every email sent and
received by the accounts waiting for it
to send an invoice let's say company a
is charging a client one million dollars
to refinance a property loan as soon as
the company sends the invoice harsha's
team gets to work making an exact copy
of it the only thing they change is the
bank account number now the team creates
an email account almost exactly like the
one that usually sends the client's
invoices maybe the real company email
address is this so hush's team adds or
removes a letter from it like this it
may seem obvious now as i show you but
when you're accepting an invoice from an
email that looks sort of like this and
you get that invoice at the time you're
expecting to get it it's super easy to
miss this exact scheme actually happened
to someone very close to me so the
client gets an email from kelsey
apologizing for a mistake on the first
invoice and instructing them to follow
the instructions on this new error free
invoice the client just thinks few that
was close and deposits the money into
the new accounts the account controlled
by hush puppy himself with the money
safely in hush's eager hands the email
account is deleted and every trace of
the scammers disappears into thin error
and the money it gets laundered to
distance itself from the original
transaction and then some of it gets
divided up and set to members of the
team while most of it stays with hush
hush's role in this whole scheme was to
provide the bank accounts over the years
him and his team stole almost half a
billion dollars from almost anyone they
could a children's hospital in qatar a
law firm in america anyone who was
gullible enough to fall for their scheme
saw their company lose millions in most
cases no one wanted to go public with
their loss what law firm wants to
advertise the fact that they got scammed
out of a million dollars by some guy
online at one point hush and his team
were even planning on scamming an
english football club out of 300 million
dollars luckily the plan didn't go
through and for years the fbi had been
tracking down the people responsible for
one of the most successful online
rackets in history when they finally
arrested hush's two friends one of them
had his phone on him and on that phone
they found messages to a snapchat
account called hush puppy asking for
banking details to use on a new scam
unfortunately for hush puppy he had
gotten a little too comfortable with his
life as a multi-millionaire scam artist
he connected all his social media to his
phone number and email and using nuts
the epia had finally been able to start
looking in the right direction the
birthday party was just the cherry on
top here they had hush puppy partying
with confirmed internet scammers it was
all they needed to arrest him and send
him to prison for a very very long time
if there's one lesson we can learn from
this is that if you make your money in a
sketchy manner which i'm not advising
you to do learn a little something from
our men hush and keep your flexing to
your close friends list
[Music]
what's up guys hope you guys enjoyed the
video super cool story that i want to
share with you guys and if you're new
here my name is jake and we make
documentaries on money power and crime
multiple times a week for free so if you
enjoyed this one click that subscribe
button below and if you want longer more
controversial documentaries that are too
controversial to be posted publicly
click that join button below i'm
actually working on one right now i know
it's a little bit delayed but it's
definitely gonna get demonetized so
it'll be good and if you join and you
don't think it's worth it there's a
refund policy so you can just email me
and i will personally refund you the
money that's going to wrap it up you can
follow me on instagram my jaketrend.io
stay dangerous out there and i'll see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you